[موسيقى]
لم تمت امجاد اوكرانيا
ولن نسمح بهيمنه الاخرين على اراضينا
يجدد الاوكرانيون عهدهم ذاك بكلمات سلامهم
الوطني كلما عزف
عزف هنا في بولندا التي عبر الرئيس
الاوكراني الحدود اليها في رحلته المستمره
بحثا عن مزيد من الدعم
[موسيقى]
وبحثا في هذه اللحظه بالذات عن حشد دولي
لايقاف الحرب الروسيه على بلاده
افتكر بولودمر زيلينسكي من نظيره البولندي
اندريد دوده وعدا بالسعي للحصول على
ضمانات امنيه اضافيه لاوكرانيا في قمه
الناتو المقبله ذاك امر جيد لكن اكثر ما
تلحكيه في طلبه من الشركاء الغربيين هو
تسريع وتيره الدعم العسكري
فعلى جبهات القتال في شرقي البلاد تحديدا
وضع لا يخفي الاوكرانيون انه صعب للغايه
بناء على معطيات الميدان المعلن منها
والمتكتم عليه تشكر الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
قواتها نقصا في الاسلحه والذخائر لكن ماذا
حل بالدعم العسكري الغربي
جانب من هنا ناقشه قائد القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه هاتفيا مع رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه للولايات المتحده الجنرال مارك
ميلي الاتصال بحسب كيف
ركز على تسريع توريد الاسلحه والذخيره
واكد اهميه تعزيز نظام الدفاع الجوي
للقوات الاوكرانيه
يعقوب ذلك كله اعلانا واشنطن عن تقديم
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا تقدر
قيمتها بمليارين و600 مليون دولار
تشمل المساعدات العسكريه الجديده ذخائر
لراجمات الصواريخ من طراز هاي مارس وذخيره
لمنظومتي باتريوت وناس امس اضافه الى
صواريخ مضاده للدروع تستخدمها مركبات
المشاه القتاليه برادلي
لم يجد روسوبا من التعليق على حزمه
المساعدات الامريكيه الجديده لاوكرانيا
سفارتهم في واشنطن قالت انها خطوه نحو
تصعيد الازمه وتوسيع رقعه الصراع وزياده
عدد الضحايا المدنيين ودعت القياده
الامريكيه الى ان تقيم بشكل عقلاني عواقب
مثل هذه الاعمال اعمال تجدها موسكو سانحه
لتجدد التمسك بالمهام المحدده لما تسميها
العمليه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
ولتؤكد ان جميع المنتجات العسكريه الغربيه
ستدمر في ميدان القتال هناك